[Music]
have your parents ever pranked you at
all for any reason this is where this is
a weird that's going on but no no it's
fine
I want to keep watching yeah leave a
comment you would sign up for a Gina and
Nikki's only fans what are they gonna do
we got each other sick my mama's never
pranked me with anything I don't think
she would be good at it either duh my
dad's version the pranks are this he
goes oh what is that he's like he's like
I can make myself disappear
watch make you disappear watch what you
go 23o my dad is like the most annoying
thing the world is so cute like if me
and my mom get into an argument and
their fight like they're in their car
and they're not speaking to each other
he goes Oh see you hold you held my hand
first I knew you're sorry and then like
or like he'll have customers and then my
mom would come in I'll be like that's
not my wife I'm her husband my dad
cheats and games and we'll be like
you're cheating and he's like I only
cheated my wife my my old man used to
come into the room when I was a kid with
like scary gloves like [ __ ] crazy
gloves with blood and [ __ ] and then he'd
like attack us but it was never as scary
as when he's yelling at my mom all right
oh you want a traumatising one here's a
traumatized a well my dad told me that
he made up the in-and-out burger song
because we got it in an out burger in
Santa Barbara for the first time I had
never seen it before never seen that
restaurant before I was 8 years old he's
like I got a theme song for them you
think they'll go for it goes in and out
in and out that's what a hamburgers they
say in the theme song and I thought he
made it up so I wrote extra verses and I
was like we should sell it to that
and I was like no it's really good like
I made I mean I was like get some fries
game shake ultimately you're just trying
to connect your father and he played a
prank that Niki took to school and told
other kids like when kids will do the
songs he's like my dad created that song
and they're like yeah right [ __ ] you
know I think now I understand why she's
so upset with you at the whole
colorblind [ __ ] I was not that reaction
was not I was null and void because of
my dad's traumatized dramatization let
me tell you about some parental trauma
all right so my mom my stepmom now does
the taxes for our business because she
used to have our aunt do it and so I was
talking my mom she goes yeah you're all
used to do but we had to stop her from
doing it now I do it I'm like why she
goes because like we would have write
offs and stuff and your aunt would ask
us about something write offs and one
time she called us and asked us um
where's this charge for Adam and Eve
calm just projectile-vomited immediately
what is that toy shop why would you tell
me this like what I don't need to know
these things as far as I know we were
conceived my Immaculate Conception and
that is all mm-hmm I don't even know
about your [ __ ] sex life oh my dad
talks about his sex life all the time
all the time but I love it you know it's
so it's so different than my parents who
shun sex my whole life and that's why
I'm very Pro sex now because [ __ ] them
and that whole mentality and so so the
idea that like you should teach kids
like Oh sex is very bad and don't talk
about is horrible for you it's it's
really bad you know what's the craziest
thing is that my dad wasn't in my life
and that's it that's the joke I love
that joke thank you that's a really good
you know Danny convinced you that he
made up in a nutburger song Thank You
button-up interior in a way your dad's
pulling the greatest joke of all was
that he's like he disappeared I just
disappeared on my son and he hasn't
found me yet this is so not about his
funeral like two weeks after the field
like on the street like some irises like
this is like highly relatable I don't
know my dad's alive right now no idea
this is that's literally hop out so we
set the funeral why are you surprised
whatever I'm okay with my parents having
butt plugs now [ __ ] it anyway so I have
this very funny compilation video of
parents pranking their kids by
pretending to smear some [ __ ] on their
hands here we go it's going there's like
a trend happening with the parents and
the pranking here we go oh gosh and it's
actually burning a butter by the way
corpse oh gosh can you not smell it
he doesn't want to yeah he's mouth
breathing right now no no it's cool
Oh immediately oh no that's parental
trauma
[Laughter]
[Music]
Sanga one was perfect perfect oh my god
it was go what she did it like a [ __ ]
you know I got a sleight-of-hand that
[ __ ] you gotta put that poop on very
gently that was so good but yeah what
kind of print I don't know like the only
pranks I've ever done on Isaac is like
scaring him like it's uneven did you
ever do the ones cause like the the new
you know the filter is how they make it
look like the spiders are like oh I saw
one where the dad turns into a bear and
the kids in the backseat and he's like
I'm a bear I saw your dad's car see
that's a lot in the process because kids
like a bear could drive you can't see
the bear in the phone he's like I like
this one where like it's it's a it's a
semi truck but it's being towed so it's
backwards like it's facing the car
directly and like I like they wake them
they wake them up and you just see the
truck coming
woken up from your sleep just seeing a
semi just coming straight all ways like
very mean but then they rip the band-aid
off of media yeah yeah yeah like my dad
used to do this thing where he's like oh
my god the brakes are out basically well
you know we drive in and he's like oh my
god and so then all of a sudden like
you're driving and then you'll he's like
oh my god pranks I just I want to go to
your parents house and just observe no
he's just he's just kid you don't know
the group chat it's pretty funny my mom
so currently the whole like the health
[ __ ] is going on my mom is concerned
because all the the parties and the
clubs and the NuWave clubs are shutting
down and she can't be biological oh yeah
my biological my biological mom yeah yes
just like all the can't go party there's
a new way of partying like man you're
gonna have to learn how to be at home
maybe reading a book making dinner
she's like you ever they shut the sex
clubs down I break check my daughter a
lot dude hi like literally just drive
them like I was school today like it was
cool to them and in science classes what
are some embarrassing things that you
know what do you do to embarrass your
daughter one time I told her to get
dressed to go grab something to eat and
waiting the car for me so when I came
out I don't like these short short
biking shorts tank top but I tucked it
under something like a halter top I had
on like a bicycles rider hat like the
mall with like the woody woody harrelson
and wide and ketchup they will be right
there and I was just like all right we
need to talk a bill like that I said I
did the whole order all right now let me
get a kiss bill
[Applause]
you're sure about this [ __ ] my dad used
to do so like he used to he had this
huge beer belly cut and he we'd be
walking out in public and then he all of
a sudden he'd do that walk but he put
his like shirt over his belly and so
their bellies exposed he's like I've
seen so many guys do that Chinese people
do that exaggerating they were like but
as pet like that's what I mean like as a
joke it's just extremely trying to
embarrass me and my stepmom and my
stepmom and be like stop and I'm like I
don't know this man
and you could be like holding my hand
and be like this is my daughter that was
part in grocery stores like while
there's people in the aisle and be like
oh my god who did that who did that who
could it be
I think I'm I'm definitely the type of
mom that like when I pick my kid up at
school I'm gonna pull up beep beep hey
hey over here that's totally me I'm
drunk mom in the parking just blast
driving my neck my back my [ __ ]
I embarrassed my stepmom whenever we go
out so we would go out and go grocery
shopping I would just yell like I do is
every time I go visit them mom we
haven't eaten in a week you keep buying
alcohol please I do that [ __ ] at the
register she's like I'll [ __ ] kill
you when we get home I'm gonna call CPS
I'm so hungry my grown-ass woman
grown-ass [ __ ] xxx a woman
and the course is related like [ __ ] I
wouldn't even card you my favorite thing
though it just gives me that like hey is
scaring Steve if I hear him coming home
I had like right underneath like where
the door like so you can't see me
through the door window thing and he
opens the door I just stand there and he
goes why I had the worst reactions for a
prank so that ever turn alee I like to
follow him from behind I'll be doing
dishes like a good man and I'll sneak up
from behind and Kent up right like right
behind his back and then he turns around
he goes think that's a prank I think
you're just excited to see your husband
when he gets home beause you got to go
over there and just like poke his
butthole a little bit I tried to be here
no no I will [ __ ] chopper leg off oh
my god that was later but I don't play
the butthole stuff either but I'll chop
her leg off I will find a way I'm just a
[ __ ] wall I know that that's
something you don't like I have to get
even more no no no no Casey hates being
tickle if I just can't help it I'm like
huge that's one thing but buttholes of
but I will take it to the next level
just my [ __ ] I'm literally gonna [ __ ]
in every left seat yeah don't I don't
play with that [ __ ] at all like butthole
and calling me a [ __ ] don't do it
you know but my favorite thing my
favorite thing nikki has ever said to me
was I love whenever Steve cooks dinner
because the best part is watching them
have to eat it
watch it give up to eat his own food the
bugs at me I like eating my food [ __ ]
you look the worst part about that I
[ __ ] covered in hot sauce it like
makes your eyes swell up cuz it's
wait me that know that like any human
being now walks into the room it's like
I'm not making it for you it's for me
but it's the blandest most potent thing
I've ever ever seen yeah guess what
that's why I cover it in [ __ ] hot
sauce
I had this next to me the whole time how
the seasoning though Oh what it is
[Music]